with us on zoom and welcome along as
well to lindsay mckenzie on zoom
i have
no apologies i haven't formally received
any apologies
which moves us on to the public forum
there were no items of public forum
there are two items that were being
briefed on shortly but nothing in the
public forum section
which brings us speedily along
to the uh the youth council
so ryan in brooklyn i think no it's not
looking like a rhyme
yes oh sorry yep
didn't see you sitting on the other side
ryan sorry
cured her
counsellors welcome along
thank you
uh
[Music]
my name is ryan frost and i will be
reporting to you this evening with
brooklyn so
about a week and a half ago
ryan and i had the opportunity to attend
festival for the future in wellington
as it was a pretty incredible experience
and the point of feast for the future
was to ultimately discuss issues that
are affecting young people in new
zealand and the actions that we can take
to
help
stop these issues and to prevent them so
there is a big focus over equality and
climate change and also with the
possible
possibility of a looming recession after
the pandemic
um
the program of events focused on
langatahi and each morning there were
three keynote speakers then we went into
our breakout sessions there were two of
these
throughout the day and then we had three
more speakers in the afternoon to
finish us off
um i
think my favorite speaker was definitely
uh schneel lao who has been a driving
force in the
banning conversion therapy in new
zealand which was
had its first reading at parliament over
the weekend
yes
first of all for the future for me was a
very valuable experience
uh many speakers provided a good insight
into their life experiences and some of
the challenges that they faced and how
they overcome those challenges uh the
workshops that were provided there were
a cool experience i personally uh
attended a shed an investing one held by
shizzi's and that was uh very
interesting to attend and see some of um
fellow youth's opinion on some of the
matters and how they
viewed investing and savings
we also attended a mural lunch when we
arrived
which we were greeted by andy foster the
mirror of wellington and then he uh held
a 15-minute presentation
and greeted us to the festival then
there was a small
lunch
yes uh also i would like to on behalf of
myself and the youth council i would
like to greatly thank the council and
the invercargill ratepayer for affording
us the opportunity to be able to go to
the festival for the future as we
believe it was a
valuable experience for ourselves and
youth council to be able to attend a
festival like this so thank you
um i think that's pretty much it for the
festival for the future uh recently at
youth council uh
last week we had a meeting where kirsten
harper the city center coordinator
from great south came to speak to us and
she took us to
the
information hub for the cbd and we had a
we tour around there and got to see some
of the progress that has been made on
the city center development
we also took a walk outside around the
back of reading cinemas and got to look
at the construction
uh some questions were asked about the
presentation amy hibbs
who the presentation amy hibbs presented
about the progress being made and we
believe that it was
very cool to see
the progress
that had been accomplished so far with
some of the halfway milestones
that we've come to
we also spoke about the city centre
streetscapes program uh project
um where we looked at the terms of
how progress was just getting started
and we believe that was
really interesting to see
and
yeah we believe it's very important and
it's great to see that the city streets
upgrade is now beginning
yeah
any questions
so um thank you for that uh and can i
also acknowledge councillor cracker who
gave up her weekend to attend the
festival for the future um with our
youth council representatives i i'm keen
to understand how you think um going to
an event like that's helped you develop
personally you know in in developing
leadership skills and a sense of voice
yeah
um for me
anyway i found it um
very valuable uh i personally had never
been to anything like that uh before so
i mean it was good for some personal
growth for myself because i had
never flown or stayed anywhere by myself
so that was a good thing for me
personally
um but it was also in a sense inspiring
to see some of the
challenges
because all around us were always hear
about many of these challenges that we
face in life and to see that these
people and many of these speakers not
only acknowledge those challenges but
actually presented a way of how they
overcome these challenges and
actually had a solution to
the problems that we face rather than
just
continuing to state more problems
thank you councillor pottinger
thank you chair um a couple questions
the first one
is as with us going to the
local government conference in blenheim
four weeks ago
did you find mingling with other
like-minded
junior people from new zealand and
sharing ideas and
and finding out the different problems
they have uh to what you guys have i
mean sharing information is an important
thing at these conferences did you have
a chance to
to sort of mix and mingle yeah there
were plenty of opportunities to talk to
um other youth counselors i personally
at the investing
uh workshop i met uh some wellington
youth counselors and i also saw the
southland youth council this year and we
um sort of discussed what we thought of
all the speakers and some of the
topics that they had been had been
discussed thanks and my my other
question that i can't resist is the did
you did you talk about the 16
year voting age
uh no i do um no there wasn't a topic
that was brought up
that i
heard of uh at the festival anyway right
was there any talk about it uh not by
any of the speakers that presented
quite possibly between amongst other
people but no one i came into contact
yeah thanks for that
councillor crackit
um i would like to
move the report but also make comment on
the um three major things that i thought
really were really valuable about this
festival for the future and i can't
actually stress how fantastic this uh
conference was like it was actually put
together so well but in a fashion that
is
given to you in a digestible format for
young rangatahi like i'm not sure how
many people in this room knows what
cancel culture is but um
that's just something that is uh rife in
rangatahi or you know um on social media
and in the internet and stuff these days
and if a lot of a lot of the time
some of the older demographic and that
kind of thing and the kinds of things
that you expect rangatahi to communicate
with these days it doesn't resonate in
the way that they communicate so for me
one of the huge standout points was that
all of this content was delivered in a
manner that was actually digestible for
the rangatahi to
um
to empathize with i suppose um it was
really cool to see lots of work streams
that typically are some of the things
that
um young people say that they don't get
to taught in the in this in the
education system that we have today like
how to have a growth mindset was one of
the work streams they also had like ryan
said about sharesies and how to manage
your wealth with xero and things like
that that you wouldn't um that you don't
typically see
one of the most inspiring things uh
because there was a huge social element
to it as well and there was a a young
politician the youngest politician in
new zealand actually her name is uh
sophie hanford and she's a carpenter
district councillor
um or company councillor and she uh led
the school strike for climate change
she's a really incredible example of
somebody their age that has led a
national
um something of national significance
that has now as a result of that we have
climate change zero response um oh sorry
the climate change response zero carbon
a member bill as a result of her action
so i mean it's demonstrative of that
somebody doesn't matter who you are how
old you are can take that kind of
national action and get a result out of
it
so um yeah i'd like to thank uh the
ratepayer it was actually my birthday
while i was away
i'm not on that weekend
for giving me the opportunity and the
honor to take our young rangatahi up
there and be involved
thanks councilman
thank you councillor
um just one last thing um before we go
uh we just have a question for council
uh we'd just like to know uh if council
yet has yet to develop a stance on three
waters reform and what that would be and
if so not yet um come to a conclusion if
that
a report could be sent to youth council
i think councillor crackit and i will
explain that at the next meeting but
council does not have a position at this
point
okay that's
fine thank you
thanks for your question
uh any further questions for our youth
council representatives
no if not it's been moved and seconded
that the report is received i'll put
that all in favor
against
kerry thank you very much for uh
we are out of holidays now getting out
of school early and coming along to
speak to your report really appreciate
it and pleased to hear that you enjoyed
the experience in wellington thank you
thanks
because that moves us up to the next
item which is an update from the
southland and otago regional engineering
collective
uh kerry welcome along if you'd like to
take a seat
thank you
kiara thank you very much for the
invitation to come along and
speak to you all i must say i find it a
little bit intimidating speaking up to
such articulate and intelligent
young people
so um
yes i feel quite a lot older now um
thank you as i said for the invitation
to come and talk to you um this
emerged after a conversation between
claire hadley and i about what soric is
and
what um
its objectives are and potential are to
make a difference in south and and otago
and we thought it was a great
opportunity to explain
more about the organization what our
objectives are what we've achieved and
what our plans are for the future so
i have a um
presentation but please
feel free to ask any questions as i'm
moving through so
sorek sorak surek people call it all
sorts of different things
we have an acronym because it's the
south and an otago regional engineering
collective which obviously rolls off the
tongue
and
we are focused on south and and otago
but our
priority area is manufacturing
engineering
across those two regions across the
broader southern region
um in terms of
when we were established and how we were
are funded and set up
sorek was officially established in
2020
just before the the world went a little
bit crazy um to
last for three years to establish itself
within the sector and across those
regions
with the support of the provincial
growth fund so we are fully funded
through pgf for a period of three years
to support that sector and its long-term
growth
around the same time a number of
projects were funded
um for specific capital investments
through the pgf
um for specific pieces of machinery that
were designed to improve productivity or
were innovative in their approach that's
separate to sorek
but emerge from the same conversations
around regional economic growth
so in terms of our mission
our very broad mission is future
proofing our trade the manufacturing
engineering sector
um
that's huge um when you uh but obviously
it comes across
a very straightforward mission when you
put it into four four small words
um
the benefit of an organization such as
sorek uh which is able to act
independently on behalf of its
its member organizations
is that we are able to be nimble and
agile and respond to the needs of our
sector both now and into the future
we have four very broad priorities which
were originally identified back in
night 2018 2019
as part of a survey across the sector
to
obviously
pre-pgf funding what does the sector
need in order to grow effectively into
the future and these four themes emerged
and despite the global shocks we've had
since then remain our areas of focus
remain relevant today
so the first one of that is in building
the sector's capability
what we are trying to
achieve as an organization help the
sector achieve is
to think um within a future growth
mindset particularly when it comes to
new and emerging technologies
and within that i'm talking about things
like robotics
automation
programming all these extra skills that
people are having to try and bring into
our sector to be able to be competitive
as competitive as we can
most of those fall within a very broad
banner of industry 4.0 but it's a
a future focus a future mindset that
will help us as a sector
in our growth objectives
another
broad priority is in attracting work
we recognize that
southland and otago as a manufacturing
engineering sector work very well
together that's not the case we know
that's not the case across the country
and
globally as well we know it's
we know it's a real strength of our
sector the ability
and the general want to be able to work
together
successfully and build on those informal
partnerships that we have already
established quite well so
through strengthening those connections
and those collaborations our aim is to
compete for new work
outside of our region whether that be
across new zealand or broader um
globally as well
sectors that we're
thinking about and targeting in this in
this field are defense
um aquaculture space for example
another priority
and
this i would argue is uh
most significant and underpins
everything we do
is developing our trades people
we hear from
this sector and i know more broadly that
this is not just
something that's
unique to our sector but common more
broadly across the labour market
is that industry needs more
fit for purpose um
regional apprenticeships uh attracting
more
young people to our sector retaining
people and upskilling people within our
sector as well
this is and has become a
huge priority for us and i'll talk to
you in a moment about some of the work
we're doing in that area
the fourth and final
main priority is in advocacy
creating conditions for sustainable
change across the sector
we knew that in its uh early days of um
creation at zorek that advocacy would be
one of our roles
then of course cobot came along and the
ability to
advocate for the needs of our sector
within a a rapidly changing dynamic
environment was very important so we
worked
very closely with um other stakeholders
argued for the need for support for our
sector
that's changing over time the the focus
of that advocacy but the role that our
sector plays in
stimulating sustainable economic
recovery is something that we continue
to
talk to people about whenever when
everyone stops to listen
slide i've got up here
even i struggle to read from over here
um but just illustrate some of the depth
of the connections that we have at sorek
we have members we loosely call the
members although when
don't charge any fees for um liaising
with us
um
falls into a number of key areas
including business support community
groups
um education still skills development
focused bodies for example
it's very complex
in terms of the types of bodies and
organizations that we try and liaise
with at some level frequently
i put that up there though as an example
of
how we are able to maximize our ability
to achieve the outcomes that we were
trying to by working collaboratively
with other people
through sorry through um
the covert 19 lockdowns last year for
example we realized that to maximize our
capability we need to be working with
bodies such as great south and helping
them in the work they were doing to
reach out to businesses
so that's just a very broad overview
to talk about the work we are doing more
specifically this is a
very brief lift of some list of some of
our key areas of focus so i mentioned
before advocacy is a key role
finding new markets and opportunities is
something we're continuing to engage in
wherever we can with relevant government
bodies
through
government departments that liaise
specifically with global organizations
with regional development agencies
anybody that we can make sure that our
sectors kind of on the on the page in
front of them
capability mapping
is another key piece of work we are
undertaking at the moment
i mentioned before about trying to
improve our
capacity and capability across the
sector
we have very quickly realized that to do
that effectively we needed to understand
what
we could already do what the gaps are
where we could improve
and how we could tell and sell the story
of our region from a manufacturing and
engineering perspective to attract more
work
so that capability mapping exercise is
underway it's in its very final stages
and we will soon be
releasing some draft material to people
across the sector
then that net worth network growth and
building connections pieces is also
hugely important
particularly when we're experiencing
shared issues in fields for example such
as
unreliable supply chains externally
some of the
really big problems the sector is facing
at the moment
skills and education i've highlighted
there i mentioned before it underpins
everything we do
it's pointless having a very
well kitted out and competitive sector
if we don't have people that can staff
and deliver on our promises so it has
become
a major focus for us
what i'd like to briefly talk about next
is a program that we launched officially
last friday
which was the um sorek engineering
academy it very much does what it says
on the tin
it's um an academy that we have
established as a
highly innovative and quite unique
partnership between industry and
education
the pilot at the moment running through
south otago i'll touch on that again in
a moment
the aim is to provide learning
opportunities for senior high school
students in the engineering sector
so we have established
a highly immersive
highly integrated program that's not for
credit and this is where it starts to
differentiate itself to gateway style
programs
to give students an understanding
of what engineering could look like to
them as a career opportunity
the key point here though is we want
them to remain at school and complete
their ncea while they're gaining that
experience we don't want to attract
students out of an industry prematurely
we want to give them a really rich
experience while they're still at school
we know that there are huge benefits
already to students businesses
and the wider community
the program has been up and running for
six months
yes we had a launch on friday but we
um
had minister stuart nash there who was
very interested in what the program was
about so we had held that as an official
launch launch
and an announcement that we are going to
be rolling that particular program out
which currently lives in balclutha
across dunedin and invercargill and we
have a couple of other regions as well
in mind to
target for for an initiative like this
up on the screen there you'll see that
we have
a number of partners involved in this
which makes it
in its establishment a fairly admin
heavy
type program
but we've got five businesses
three schools
and the ministry of education
working together under the banner of
sorek to give students
a learning opportunity that they
wouldn't have elsewhere
those students
are able to
complete a rotational placement so every
every term they go to one of these
businesses spend a term there observe
complete a project they're building a
tool chest and a workbench
as well as observing things like
what leaning manufacturing looks like
um what a small business looks like um
what um
in the case of somebody like calder
stewart what it looks like to be part of
a steel factory within a major
organization
they're also learning
how to talk to
people on the shop floor how to behave
at smoko what to dress
what happens if they can't come in that
day those employability skills that are
really really important
other partners involved in this are
bodies such as mb
msd
funding providers philanthropic bodies
for example and then as we think about
rolling that program out now that we
know it works um other initiatives such
as seth and youth futures and how we can
integrate with some of those
programs that have similar objectives in
in supporting young people
the
what next is
as i mentioned rolling the program out
and what we are doing now is working
with
schools and businesses that we know will
be able to step up and work with us in
this
we're really really mindful that
particularly when it comes to businesses
there's a huge time commitment to
something like this
however
they're also very keen to ensure that
we're able to um
meet future labor market needs by
inspiring and attracting young people
into the sector
we in southland will be working with um
moroccan regeneration to ensure that
we're able to work together and meeting
common needs and objectives
and
to do that we'll be continuing to work
with ministry of education and nb
particularly
ideally
and my board chair announced this in
front of everybody
on friday without telling me first minor
heart attack but it's okay um we want to
have at least 100 people engaged in a
program like this next year and moving
forward
so we've got some some big ambitions for
this particular program
this list in front of you now is a list
of some of the outputs that soric has a
an eye on
some of these are specifically relating
to the academy type model
um others are more generally in terms of
attracting new work creating new jobs
improving productivity promoting
sustainable growth as big ticket items
that we really hope we can help try and
make a difference with as an
organization
finally just to talk about um
sorek and its future
i've already talked to you about the
engineering academy and i'll focus on
that in the future but more broadly um
we are very keen to improve
or support the development of the the
workforce and the manufacturing
engineering labor market more generally
so we're also looking at managed
apprenticeship programs and working with
providers in that space as well
we're working with sit otago poly for
example in how we can work with them to
ensure that there's that industry
education connection
and then looking at professional skills
development and then skills needs of our
current workforce when it comes to
preparing itself for the future and that
future focus is something that comes up
a lot we're talking about skill shifts
and mindset shifts and so on
capability mapping and developing
capacity i've talked about
and
very generally we are
in a position where we're trying to make
a difference to our sector
we're relatively uniquely placed to do
that and with our south and an otago
focus
we're able to ensure that what we're
doing is specifically relating to the
needs of our our region
i am conscious i've probably given you a
whole heap of information
very quickly um but i did just want to
give you a general overview of what
we're trying to do what we've achieved
so far
from your perspective um
it would be
wonderful for sorry to be kept in mind
for any
discussions around
um labour market within this space the
needs of our sector and general
promotion of us and what we're trying to
achieve so
that's pretty much all i wanted to say
if you have any questions or comments
more than happy to answer thanks kerry
the um the program the transition
program that you've rolled out at
roxboro
south otago and tokomariano high schools
are you looking at introducing that to
any of the schools in the infrared
region absolutely yes so that's that's
the rollout that we're focusing on next
and we have a number of schools and
businesses in mind that have some have
already
we've created a bit of a fear of missing
out on this as many have approached us
already and said we want to be part of
this
um
and we are putting
something together that will meet them
their needs as well as industry um what
we are very keen to do is make sure that
we're establishing or rolling out
something that's fit for purpose and not
a generic model that
has to be the same everywhere we want to
make sure that we can retain that
ability to be
nimble and meet local need
so with what you're achieving at the
moment throughout otago and south and is
are the issues the same across our
borders within the otago south and
greater region um
mostly yes sometimes it's the same but
slightly different
um i mean we're dealing with um some
very different businesses but but
broadly the issues that we're facing
across those two regions are the same or
similar
the the fundamental issue that's the
same but across both of those areas is
that
genuine desire to work together to make
a difference and that collaboration and
that connected integrated supply chain
is something that
we're really good at and that we want to
build even more
thank you
and and thank you for your presentation
and expectation of what our role is from
sorek's perspective as well council is
it's open for questions or comments
counselor clark you just want one quick
question in relation to what you've
delivered it seems to me that you're
very much pitched at the um
the trade end
and potentially enticing young people
into the industry through
apprenticeships and and other things
that a little bit less formal than that
i wonder what's at the other end of the
scale which is the tertiary end as well
so so one of the big gaps that we've
identified
is the whole three waters area
so reform going on there and it's a
significant shortfall of water engineers
for a water specialist and whether
that's something that falls within your
group's horizon i guess
thank you um and absolutely agree with
you yes the the sorak engineering
academy
has its focus
at the moment on the trades end you're
absolutely right um
that's one component of our focus um we
in terms of the future skills need and
those that industry 4.0 piece we also
need to be looking at
um
higher education and its offerings as
well as upskilling our current workforce
as well
we
um as an organization are still
relatively
really quite small so there's a you know
we have to focus our efforts to where
they'll have the most impact but those
three areas
high school students
students already in education and beyond
within our current workforce are
absolutely where we want to make a
difference
thank you
thank you councillors any further
questions
if not thank you for taking the the time
to come along and present sorry your
aims and objectives this afternoon we
appreciate it and look forward to
working with you collaboratively to see
how we can help in the future fantastic
thank you i've got some brochures here
on who we are and what we do so i'll
leave those with you thank you thank you
castle is our next item is an update
from thriving south and
mr kyle
just um i'm sorry
just for transparency i should just the
counselors note that i'm chairman of
thriving southland
but my good colleague richard will do
the presentation because he's much
better at this than me
thanks jeff richard welcome to the
meeting welcome thanks very much for the
invitation to come along and um bring
you up to speed or
i thought i'd bring you up to speed with
where thriving south is at but also
a few of you won't know where we come
from and and
i suppose we're what our aims are and
what we're trying to achieve
um so thriving southland was set up um
about two and a half years ago and it
was uh in a response to
a lot of
i suppose regulation
different
greenhouse gases climate change a whole
lot of different issues coming at the
primary sector and it was actually set
up by a group of farmers who said
there's got to be a better way through
this a more positive approach um to
change
um and
that's that was the i suppose the
beginning of thriving southland and then
we were approached by the ministry of
primary industries around looking at how
we could
help farmers with regulation that was
coming
at them and tell them what they needed
to do
um
and added that um cut we we got funding
from the sustainable land use contract
through mpi for six million dollars over
three years
but the i suppose the the difference was
um
already in south into a catchment groups
in southland and
we said we went and we said to npr well
actually why don't we start working from
the ground up around solutions rather
than
top-down solutions so
our
values and and uh vision are
inspire community action and that's
actually
uh in in the rural sector in the primary
sector
um but as as we've developed what's
happened is the communities have got
involved the rural communities have got
involved in the across the board
and the linkages have been recognized
with
the farming community right across the
board so we've we've moved on
i suppose we've moved on to a place
where we're now working with um
community groups uh community catchment
groups right throughout southland so
this is some of the challenges that were
uh and there's there's more to add to
that list um that we're coming at
farmers and no direction
and
really it was causing a whole lot of uh
stress and it still has and you've
probably seen the response to that in in
recent weeks um
and so thriving south and we we went out
to uh
we went out to the catchment groups and
and we said you know what what do you
need
and that and they said we we want to
know the information the science we want
to we want assistance because a lot of
these catchment groups and community
groups are run by one or two people
and tend to get a lot of burnout
we want to know direction
and we want to be part of of moving and
changing things
so this is a sort of the current
approach the current
approach to the easy approach to change
which is
the world view of where the problem is
create the model
throw out the mitigation design policy
around it
and then and then build build the answer
to that and funding comes into that and
it's a circular model and and that tends
to be the model we see um with a
top-down approach
so the thriving southland approach is
obviously a lot more and you'll see on
the screen it's a bit of a um it's it's
a messy a messy model in a sense but
it's about actually bringing everybody
into the into the conversation around
what are the issues
um what what are the opportunities
and and and putting the people who have
to create the change at the center of
that so that's um that's where thriving
south and sees its role and we we talk
to
uh the catchment groups about what do
they need and and we also introduce
information uh put clarity around some
of the science um we've we've done a
piece of work on a science water quality
lip review of all the sites that were
sat in the water space
the environment southland and put it in
a
document that you can actually sit down
and read through and make some sense of
that and when you start putting
information in front of farmers they
start looking for solutions and
communities start to
be part of that
so the um
here we go um
so the key areas uh that we've been
working in is obviously the support of
of the catchment groups we've got four
four catchment coordinators who go out
and help work
uh help the group with their plans and
uh
working out with their direction their
vision and values it's about them
the the catchment groups are actually
all independent we we we sit in between
uh the funder and the catchment group so
they're independent they look at the
projects they want to work on and they
drive the changes that they're
interested in
engagement we have we have comms when we
link our catchment groups through
facebook we've got a
website um and so we're constantly
putting information out to them uh
linking linking them together and
building uh engagement around the
catchment groups
i've mentioned the science
the science is really important to um
farmers certainly in a space of change
water quality greenhouse gases
um even farm systems
so we've we've
we're working on projects in those areas
to actually looking at reductions in
greenhouse gases with
improvement in water quality but that's
that's the information we give to the
farmers and they they work through this
information
cooperation clarity and duplication that
was a real feat strong feedback from the
community they didn't want
more of the same doubling up
um wasting funds
so we work with the stakeholders
um we've got a relationship talking with
ewey about their messaging and how that
needs to come through in the in the
change of around water quality
um we we also work with the yes um
environment southland and we're starting
to talk with processors so everybody's i
suppose it's bringing everybody into the
room about the conversation we've got
processors who are looking
internationally around consumers looking
for low footprint
that's a positive drive it's a positive
drive for change rather than a negative
these are the problems we've got
um
and then local knowledge uh we've put um
the local history together
of of the area for catchment groups
individual catchment groups um they've
also got their own um
we're working on brochures around their
own science for their own area it's
really important that when the catchment
group started we thought there would be
a four major catchment groups around
just um
around the um
fresh water management units which are
the the main rivers the iridi the
aparima the matera and the wire
and we thought we'd have these six
groups we've ended up we're actually now
28 um
we ended up at 28 catchment groups and
that's because they sit around their
community and it's really and we've
found that's really important they work
alongside the people they know
the people they trust
and and that's how they get engagement
and then they start working together in
in bigger groups around bigger projects
so such as a project in the aparima
where all the six
catchment groups are joined together
it's called the ace group and that's all
they're looking at the whole
river system and
how they can
work alongside each other in that space
so we say we've got to focus key focus
is profit and resilient farm systems so
as we
see change it's actually maintaining
resilience
in the primary sector and it's really
important that we do that and
certainly there's going to be quite a
challenge in the next few years around
nutrient reduction
and that will have an impact on our farm
systems and how we manage them
and it's important that um it's
important for the region that we say
that that resilience stays there
innovation and adaptation so that's
bringing new ideas to the table
uh and sharing them among
the people doing the work
environmental sustainability it all it
all links together it's not one or the
other and finally the emotional and
physical
and mental well-being
uh and we believe that actually by
giving the direction and and having
having uh having some answers and
solutions and people working on their
own answers and solutions
that's uh that's a real key um
around the the mental uh health and
well-being that people can see the way
forward so we've we do have um
we've got projects that range from uh
riparian planting uh understanding your
your catchment and where where is the
best place for
wetlands riparian planting we're also
doing some work with
uh land and water science with a group
of farmers in the hedgehog
catchment uh and also in the wendy's
side catchments and and they're looking
at um
basically what's under the hood in their
in their farm just uh on in on the land
looking at physiographic and radiometric
data which actually tells them where
where the the best areas are for
mitigations
within the farm system
but it also we're looking at nitrous
oxide layers as well so with an
attachment there may be
areas where
greenhouse gases are emitted and where
they can be um
mitigated so and when you put that in
front of
the people on the ground they start
putting that together and actually
coming up with solutions so that's just
some of the work um we're currently
undertaking
um
there's a some of the events we we bring
speakers uh in the
as the catchment groups have asked for
speakers they want to know where things
are going and what things are looking
like so we bring speakers in looking at
so we've had the future farm expo
the aqua van was a linkage and i think
that's where
a linkage with the urban community
we had 700 children in invercargill and
and gore come through and look at the
acrovan and the catchment catchment
model
and that's really also really important
we know we're all connected right down
through to the new river estuary and
it's important and has been important
for farmers for urban engagement as well
so we've got a range of um
uh projects on on the go and that we've
got another two years
in
uh yeah
to before we're looking for the next
round of funding yeah thanks
thank you richard
councillors it's here for any questions
or comments you have councillor clark
uh richard you i think your chairman was
quite right that you're by far a better
um presenter than he would have been
um
just one issue i i noticed that you're
very your group seems to be quite
reactive
um to
issues that are presented to the farming
sector are they also proactive as well
so like are they
um
getting to government um
government thinking about around things
like smas and other things that have
caused issues the recent times the the
um we're a political okay um and when uh
so we they are i would say that they're
um
the lead farmers within our catchment
groups are looking at the issues that
are coming at them and how to how to
manage them yeah but as as far as
thriving south and we're apolitical the
catchment groups have their own opinions
and um
yeah but they they're i would say
they're actually um they're
a leading in some of the thinking
certainly around how to mitigate some of
the challenges sure thank you
councillor bottinger thank you chair
richard just looking at your um
i'm on the map here that shows the
catchment groups areas and it seems that
invercargill rural
um seems to be missed out a wee bit is
that is that something that's actually
phil it's the way tuna sits there as
well and the white we we don't have a
catchment group in the white tuna
um but the the new revolutionary forum
sort of sits on it okay it just shows it
shows before there and it's greyed out
yeah
with the fjords and everything i was
just wondering yeah you know those
farmers that are obviously right they
link into they link into the the
tiano farmers and at that they they link
into the y o catchment okay yes
it's probably um as a region uh we'll be
the furthest ahead as with our region is
pretty well covered with catchment
groups compared to
the rest of the country but we're seeing
that start to
seeing a lot of catchment groups move
throughout the country now
yeah i think we're in a good position
so my other question was regard
regarding carbon farming
yeah is that something that that you
know with farmers being under a lot of
stress and
um taking uh the option of just bailing
out and
planting in trees you know really good
productive
i would land yeah we we certainly hear
that from farmers um and
our roles to put the information in
front of them to make decisions too
right to look at that yeah yeah thanks
any further questions counselors
if not thank you richard for not only
the presentation but the answering of
questions this afternoon we appreciate
it thanks very much
castle is the next item item seven which
is the minutes of the community
wellbeing fund committee from june 17th
councillor lewis thank you mr chair
in
confirming the minutes of this meeting
i would like to actually
make extra note of the well-formed
applications we've had for this
committee
this committee's funding round often
with the help of our staff so special
thanks to the staff for doing so
it's quite a
quite a full meeting
taking most of the afternoon and i think
particularly the for the members ten for
giving that afternoon up with all the
preparation they have to do for the
reading and but more particularly the
staff to help so i'd like to formally
move
when it's be confirmed
thank you councillor seconder
councillor skill
so the minutes are being received
thank you i thought that all in favor
against
carried need your assistance with the
next one too i'm happy to move that the
minutes
for the uh hearings for the
environmental reserve's omnibus draft
management plan be received i shall
secondly be received thank you
it's a recommendation that comes up
later in the agenda let's be moved and
seconded any questions or comments
if not i put the motion all in favor
against kerry
minutes from the performance policy and
partnerships committee held on the 13th
of july
i'll move those thanks councilman
and councillor sopa
any matters arising
if not i put the motion all in favor all
right against
carried
that brings us to the quarterly report
up to the 30th of june
and receiving the report going to take a
moment to acknowledge the fact that
we're now up to date so as we integrated
a new reporting system at headmint we
were running just a little bit behind
time over the past couple of reports but
we're only just into august and we've
got the year-end 30th of june
so welcome jamie and patricia thanks um
while we do have a report for 30th june
i do want to emphasize these are draft
numbers
they will be different to the numbers
you'll see when we bring you the annual
report later in the year
because we are still going through with
a fine-tuned comb
making sure we've got things in the
right place
so this is a draft but it gives an
indication of where we are
do you wanna
um yes so just on that um so we're
currently showing a surface of nine uh
not mine four point
that was the right way around you want
to revise that that's fine
yeah so it's currently sitting at 4.9
however we've still got a number of
accounting adjustments we need to make
and one of the big ones is
revenue recognition of the treatment of
the subsidies received for the shovel
ready and three water projects
um so
the money we've received for that is
about 4.5 off top of my head um some of
that will be still kept as revenue for
the share but there will be proportion
that will that will be put to the
balance sheet as a liability and it will
lower our surplus as well
we're probably projecting um that we
will be around the break-even mark after
all these adjustments are done
which is
a wee bit better than what we had in the
annual plan any plan we had a small loss
um but
we're aiming for about break even so
that's good for us
um
so some other items just to
highlight is um so capital
spend is in line with what we had
forecast through the rtp process
but it is down by 13 million on what we
originally said in the annual plan
most of these projects have been
deferred into the first few years of the
ltp
so they are still happening
um from the net debt side of things um
so the holding company has repaid
us the um 30 million dollar advance we
provided them about five years ago
um
of which we've used those funds to repay
our borrowings so these are zero need to
impact from there
um and if you have a look at the cash
flow statement um right down the bottom
you'll see it's showing us about a 45
million dollar
cash and cash equivalents which is
typically cash at bank
um
we've applied um accounting treatment
for some of the term deposits that
mature between um july and september and
they have to be treated as cash rather
than an investment so that's why that
number stands out quite a lot compared
to where it previously used to be
but then the investments has also
dropped as well to match that off
that are the big key points i've
got otherwise is there any questions on
the report thank you so
while it's easy to get excited about
an operating surplus of 5 million or 4.9
um
essentially that comes back to square
with
payment off
from the shovel ready projects
um you're quite right to to point out
that we've moved from a deficit to to
breaking even and given the year that
we've been through that's a
a very favorable outcome
and
repayment of debt
was the other thing that was being
focused on so
i guess that helps to create headroom
moving forward rather than
is an operating surplus
um let's get excited and and see what we
can but because it's not really an
operating surplus thanks for that
there's a series of
recommendations
on page 26 to look for a mover for and
then we'll open it for debatable
discussion councillor pottinger moving
secretary councillor clark it's open for
questions or comments counselors
counselor clark
i didn't ask some questions well
there'll be something wrong um jamie
i've got a range of questions so i've
got about a dozen or so um
just wanted some clarification on page
27 of um
board books as we're working our way
through
that we've got an underspend of about
12.7 million dollars in
non-capital expenditure
am i reasonable to assume that when we
look at things like anderson's house
that's been in our planning for more
than just last year and the same for the
watertown which goes back to 2018-19
um that when
when we say we haven't spent the money
um
that when we come to doing the spending
next year
the
capital expenditure will be sitting in
our reserve accounts
the fund if that was funded from rates
yes they'll be selling the net debt
accounts yeah if they're funding from
borrowings we apply that into our
forecasts for borrowings going forward
yeah totally understand that thank you
um
on page 30
these
um
spreadsheets here there's a 660 000
shortfall of expenditure over a forecast
for rental revenue and
and i'm scratching my head trying to
think where are we falling short on our
on our rental income
um when we had a quick look at this um
there's a bit of money from parks which
was initially indicated um to arrive
this year um that hasn't
eventuated um so we will be looking at
that when we do reforecasting for next
year to make sure that is coming in or
we'll be reforecasting that to remove it
yeah i guess my perspective would be it
would be helpful
when you do the annual report to know
whether there's any shortfall occurring
in our two big investment areas which
are don street and the roof farm yep
that will be difficult i know if we
talked about net net services but
they don't necessarily include the uh
um the servicing of the debt that might
be associated with it i guess
yep so that would be helpful um
on page 33 it talks about proceeds of
sale of investments of a 12.3 million i
take it to that that's uh tied up with
the forestry company
the proceeds of sale investments will
actually be the
proceeds from the
that's the term deposits
okay that's fine
on page 35
going through board books again it talks
about
our borrowing level being at um 89
million it will take a little bit of
change
and i notice in there that we we refer
sometimes about their having a cap
at 2.5 times revenue but in fact our
lgfa cap is actually three times at the
moment isn't it
even though we might not want to be
there
yeah the possible cap is three times
yeah potentially coming back to 2.8 um
so that's quite a really positive
position if we're sitting on borrowings
of just a little bit short of 90 million
and potentially we could be at 280
million if we wanted to go right to the
cap
for our council that's a really
positive position again i guess a really
good position to be yep yep that's fine
um page 36 has got some
some figures about cash and cat cash and
cash investments seem to be totaling out
about 54 million if i take away this the
staff investment
um so that's quite a quite an increase
on last year
and just a little bit of advice on that
given our ltp is based on
uh having a baseline there of 40 million
does that give us
roughly 14 million dollars worth of
capacity to do some things that we might
need to do this year
some examples of that might be around
the museum around
funds that may be required for the block
city block um i would say no um on that
so um
a lot of this has already been earmarked
so some of these cash deposits are
already earmarked for different things
within next year's
well the current use plan so i guess
when the annual report comes out it
would be helpful to know where that's
earmarked
we've had discussion in the past with um
with dave foster when he was here about
cash being king
but that sometimes that changes
sometimes i guess and you've got low
potential to borrow from lgfa
with the annual report we will be
supplying a list of movements sure from
into the reserve accounts in our equity
and that's part of that matching those
off with investments as well
and the last thing for me is on page 40
and i see that we've got
some service delivery
issues around the bluff water supply
without any explanation what that
actually is so if you can help me with
that or somebody can help me
um
that's got a nice big red cross beside
it
erin
can you um
the bluff water supply item
is one that it's no change of status
it's one that relates to the condition
of the reticulation in bluff it was
something that i questioned when i first
arrived
and it is something that we've
essentially i guess put a standard on
ourselves of liking to meet that aaa
requirement across our network but that
would be a renewal of pretty much the
entire bluff reticulation network to
meet that standard so it's not something
that we have programmed in the long term
plan at this point in time um but it is
not a change um from what we've had
previously
yeah thank you though
thank you councillor clark councillor
crackit just on there what's the
significance difference between a b and
a
just for my note
um to be honest it's an alistair murray
question specifically around why we've
put that standard on ourselves it's not
something that
comes into the do we
comply with drinking water standards
question we comply across the board um
but then when you get down into the
technical detail of how different
supplies and reticulations are graded
that comes into that different level of
detail
thank you councillor clark just as a
supplementary it might be helpful when
we go to our annual report to get some
clarification of that
um because with three waters heading our
way it'd be helpful to know what
standard we're currently achieving um
and
even though we don't know what the water
entity will want the higher up we get
the better it is
there will be additional um
commentary added to these activities
thank you thanks in the end report
thank you
further questions
i've just got one quick question just on
page 29 the regulatory uh
non-financial performance i just noticed
that it's uh
sort of only 50 percent is unfavorable
is it worse than before is it going
backwards or because it had been coming
right i thought
performance
doesn't want to work
sorry counselor arnold which one were
you looking at
uh regulatory
on page 29
or mr chairman looking um
at page 39 and board books where it's
got the detail for regulatory it does
appear to be um
the same measures have been
at a similar level right for the whole
year so it doesn't it's not something
that's happened in the last quarter
on a quick look at those but that's
something that we'll get there's a lot
more work going to be done in these
particular areas for the annual report
yeah
so it hasn't worsened but it hasn't
improved either okay thank you
it stayed about the same i think was
probably
be some summation of that yeah thanks
for that
further questions
if not it's been moved and seconded
motion to receive the report and the
three notes i'll put that all in favor
aye against
carried
the next item is a proposed right-of-way
name in
relation to duns road
there's a recommendation in there which
meets our requirements
we've councillor keith seconded
councillor lewis i'm guessing it's okay
it's an old scottish term isn't it i'll
take that under advisement
i looked it up
so we moved and seconded to put that all
in favor
against
kerry
uh which brings us to
the
environmental reserve's omnibus draft
management plan
this was a an innovation i guess in in
bundling everything together um
councillor lewis and i sat and heard his
worship was with us for a portion of the
hearings as well
um
we've received the the minutes a little
earlier on
um
and we've got the recommendations that
come from the process which really it's
up to council to
receive or reject um and if we reject it
we go back and start again but
and the great thing is that we don't see
any overwhelming desire to do that but
first congratulations on the process
there seemed to be pretty good
engagement with it there was
by and large really positive feedback
uh from the submitters and then the post
submission engagement with them
seemed to work really well
as as a a trial process are you pleased
with how it's gone cassie
i am um we've we had a really good uh
lengthy uh process with um getting
together with all the key agencies
stakeholders in ewe as well so
i think that strengthened our
relationships with the groups that we
consulted with from pre-engagement
through to post consultation as well so
it'll be great to see how we go from
here
well let's test it
yeah
uh can i get a motion on the floor first
council or sopa are you moving i'm going
to do i was going to say um there's over
300 pages here it's very impressive
reading congratulations on the whole
process and
congratulations to the councillors who
um
on the hearings and i am happy to move
it all three recommendations councillor
lewis thank you mr g i'm very happy to
second that and i've much sooner got
approved because they have to read that
again let alone to get the staff to
actually rewrite it i think we would not
be
welcome
thank you
any other questions or comments
counselors counselor clark yeah
caroline in relation to uh page one
three one and one three two of your
report hard copy all
203 and 204 of board books
um there's some comments in relation to
the uh
the odata scenic reserve which i just
want some clarification on would be
helpful
um
in 5 12 10
2
on page 131 which is your hard copy it
says no
no exterior expansions to the hall will
be funded permitted so you're talking
near just about the hall are you talking
about the car park that surrounds
i'm going to take that on advice from
cassie because she actually did the
consultation around that area because is
that just to say
the actual footprint of the car park
there
so that's just saying the expansions
around the hall so if they were to
extend it out onto the car part or like
further yeah platform i understand that
so just moving forward the following
pages of 132.
um it talks about future development it
talks about um
the otatara school and the otara land
care group and i guess you'll probably
be aware that there are some suggestions
that the car parking surround the hall
should be greater
and so i just want to know what that
last paragraph which is the first of
development future development actually
means and what your viewer take on that
is my assessment that
the school may look and that's subject
to council approval of course may look
at expanding the car park there because
they've got some parking issues around
the school
which may involve freeing up a hectare
of land the scenic reserve is 40
hectares so it's about two and a half
percent so i'm just wondering whether
any of those provisions leave the door
open for an approach by
um people that are involved or whether
that it's much much more closed
so if they're proposing to expand the
car park which would potentially take up
some of the scenic reserve plans
um that would require under the reserves
act a formalized process so we'd need to
um just go for public consultation on
that for a change in the
reserve classification to allow for
extra car parking just for that portion
yep that's fine thank you
that's me done comfortable with that yep
thank you
any other questions counselors
no
if not it's been moved and seconded i'll
put that all in favor
against
carried congratulations thank you
councillors that brings us to item 13
which is the adoption of the elected
member allowance and expenses policy
and liz
is presenting the report
welcome along
thank you overly assisted by michael and
his lovely assistant give us a toil
thanks liz uh counselors have a chat
have had a chance to read through the
paper but is there anything you're
wishing to draw their attention to in
particular
um
there's very little change to what
council is already doing but it is a
requirement of the remuneration
authority that we have this policy
and that it's on our website
the two areas that i would like to draw
council's attention to is the child care
allowance for elected members as staff
we are proposing that this be left on
the table for the new triennium
a number of councils throughout the
country
have adopted it in various forms
and
some haven't adopted it at all so
our recommendation is that be left for
the new trianium
and the only other one is around
council having the ability to charge
councillors for the use of
their equipment privately
thank you just so you're aware that um
you know we have the ipads that we're
able to use
uh they're used for council business but
no doubt we've all used them personally
as well and whether or not there's a
chargeback so essentially kind of
kicking for touch and seeing where
things sit at the beginning of the next
trianium just before i go to councillor
so but is there
likely to be any um
preparation done between now and then of
of papers that'll go to the next council
yes we plan to certainly we want to do a
lot more research around the child care
proposal and the estimated costs there
are some very strict guidelines
presented by the remuneration authority
as to when it can be paid and how it can
be paid so doing some research around
that and the potential costs
thank you councillor sopa
thanks mr chia um the child care
allowance matter is what i wanted to
raise
i see the
that issue as quite an important part of
actually preparing for the next year's
elections and attracting
some candidates for those elections for
whom such a an allowance might be quite
an important matter and therefore adding
to the diversity we want to see at this
council table
so i'm rather reluctant to see it
deferred until after the next trianium
election
and i suppose i'm foreshadowing that i
would like to
suggest an amendment to um
to recommendation two
to try and achieve
some
certainty before the next triennium
in this council's decision on that
matter i think it would be unfortunate
to have it
to have it left and to have
um yet another election next year
where we might actually have a less
diverse range of
potential candidates
because we haven't got such an equity
provision available
thank you noted um i think the recommend
the suggestion was we're able to come up
with a recommendation potentially for
the next council to adopt but councillor
cricket and then councillor bottinger uh
thank you councillor ludlow i'm sure
it's not surprising that i would like to
speak in support of um councillor sopa's
amendment
um however they're like liza said the
remuneration authority is very clear on
the guidelines and they actually won't
apply to me
in my current situation with my daughter
um i see it as really uh integral that
we have it in place for the next
training as to ensure that we can remove
as many barriers to entry participation
for incoming elected members as possible
um it is about equity and about having
that same opportunity that um
right across the broad no matter who you
are and that is a clear prohibitor
thank you councillor partner
look on that same topic um for us to
move ahead before the next training to
try and speed things up wouldn't we need
costings in front of us to um something
yeah you can't sort of vote on a on a
scheme that you have
really no idea of what it may cost you
know that
just
doesn't seem right i mean would would
something come back to us that
that would
yes i i guess the the issue that's being
raised is around a matter of timing do
you want to workshop and develop uh that
part of the policy between now
and uh the end of the term or do you
want i think councillor sober raises a
good point that that moving into an
election is it just opens up um it's
like obviously we've made the call on
first pass post rather than stb but um
this does
create an opportunity for a broader
spectrum of people to apply if if we had
a figure involved it may just be
like i've got no idea what size it would
be
so
with bearing in mind that we don't have
uh emotion on the table yet
and trying to get the the feel of the
meeting
is it the the will of the committee that
we really workshop this through to come
up with a recommended policy on both of
these issues before the end of this term
is that the feeling that i'm getting
yes counselor
mr chair i was going to suggest an
amendment that referred there there's no
amendment required there's no motion yet
yeah but
i'm foreshadowing that i when we had the
motion on the floor i was going to
suggest an amendment that meant we asked
staff to do some work on
um
finding the comparable policies already
passed by other councils doing some
costings and bringing it back to a
future meeting of this committee and
workshopping it
so that was that was what i'd seen as
sensible i'm not suggesting that we
that we adopt a child care allowance
today
um i am suggesting that some more work
could be done for us to consider
adopting before
um next year
right even into early next year
preparation i'm looking at the motions
and so if we leave
recommendation one as it is
but recommendation two that um
this council continues to work on
developing this policy before the end of
the term for both of those are you
comfortable with
with that
happy to move that way you want to add
if you want to add in with staff to
bring back a report and counsel to
workshop the issue yeah
so councillors are you clear on what it
is that we're doing with items two and
three
uh staff will workshop the items staff
will develop a report and we'll have
reached a conclusion before the end of
term
okay
so councillor sub are you moving that
we haven't
put the change up were you listening yes
excellent mr chair and and
and the only other thing that perhaps if
we give staff a timetable so perhaps by
the november meeting
of this committee we could have
the first trump the first draft of a
report we've got a workshop at first and
i want to make sure first of all that
we're not jumping in on top of any other
workshops but i mean obviously we want
to have it resolved before the middle of
next year but can we leave that that
timetable uh
yep
yep
so you're moving
i'm moving thank you second second
counselor amundsen
any questions around what we're doing
councillor clark just some wider
questions and bear with me being a
first-term counsellor i'm not aware that
these um
um these policies that um these uh
provisions are available to elected
members
and whether that was missed in my
induction or not i'm not sure so if
there are current rates of prevail
um i've sadly missed
they
don't exist for us at present but the
opportunity for it to be introduced
became available to councils
i think through a consultative process
towards the end of the last the previous
term uh council voted that it supported
for example the idea of a
a child care allowance
um this is is really just uh the
mechanics of
exploring how we bring those options
about yeah no it's referring to uh more
so to page seven three seven of uh board
books which is talks about um
allows us for using personal printers
and mobile phones and the likes and
actually a daily travel allowance when
you're away from
from another car like going to
christchurch or dunedin or whatever so
that was one issue
um but the other issue is it'll be
helpful to get some staff advice when
they're coming back to us
on the tax implications of this as well
because i mean this year i was able to
claim
um quite a bit of tax relief through my
annual tax return by using uh my
personal cell phone for
council work
um the same from computers and
photocopying paper and so on it's quite
quite a long list that you can claim for
would that be and i'd like some advice
on whether that would be
changed or implicated by having an
allowance to sort of cover that as well
the allowance already exists
um
but
certainly we can go through that with
the workshop process sure
counselor cracker
i'm not an accountant but i do work for
one so um
it was my understanding that if we're
being reimbursed for what the allowance
for communications for example so say
your phone you wouldn't claim it as an
expense because it's it's you've already
been provided for example so i wouldn't
do that before you oh and i wasn't
suggesting anybody would but it might be
helpful to get some advice from staff
about
which system it's best to be in yeah
like you know would we be in the council
funded one or whether we just incur the
cost ourselves and be able to claim back
and i advise you to get an account at
council club
he might be able to give us some advice
at later stage which would which would
help but i just want to be clear that
there are some rates that apply already
i'm putting aside the childcare stuff
yep
thank you michael
through yourself the chair
um a number of these are allowances and
are already applied to the councillors
as per their remuneration um it's only
those that
fire expense claims as you will see
itemized on each individual one that you
need to put through a claims process the
ones where it stipulates allowance are
already in the remuneration as it stands
uh the new figures are what will be
adjusted going from the 1st july
so just for my clarification on that
michael so the allowances are built in
but we're still able to claim for things
like the daily travel allowance
that is correct thank you
and i think there are criteria around
that as well
it's over a certain
distance before it applies and in time
frames as well yep
yeah
thank you
so we've got a motion are there any
further questions or comments
it's not a council of pottinger it's a
very late vote
and it's it's
maybe a bit trivial
but talking about travel time now we all
few of us went to the local government
conference in blenheim and i got a
flight first thing in the morning as did
you we're up there in good time
council of krakow unfortunately
spent i think took a 10 hours from
mittenberg will do wellington now travel
time is that is this travel time
included in her
marathon no too thank you nice okay
there is there's no allowance for your
actual time
uh more the mechanical expenses of of
vehicle mileage no that is fine yeah
good question just feeling sorry for my
fellow council and no doubt it worked uh
in reverse for people trying to get home
too
okay i'm going to put the motion all
those in favor
i i am against
carried
you can lead a horse to water right that
brings us to
the item from liz which is a request
from councillor crackit to attend the
young elected members
hui uh two recommendations i'm happy
enough to move them
but they're all in favor
aye against
no issues alex enjoy it
i think we see the value in in your
attendance at that event and
and recognize the uh role that you play
with
national level as well thank you
which brings us to the activity report
um
which also includes an item that i think
i'd raised with clear a little earlier
about about ivm
when we were going through our
declarations of interest i discovered i
was still a director reviving
along with
councillor abbott there on zen waving
appropriately uh when we discovered that
even though the company is on the shelf
as the two remaining directors who are
on it that we are
part of that there were three one of the
directors is no longer a member of
council
and that's really um behind uh item two
steve is there anything else that uh
you'd like to draw our attention to
uh yeah just um a question at the last
ppp meeting was raised by councillor
scout around
patronage
of the civic and have we noticed any
trends
around
how people are engaging with our events
and richard mccoy has noted in his
report on the civic
that what we're finding is that there
are similar patterns of engagement with
the events but there's a very much a
later booking
process and people are leaving to the
last minute
because they've learnt
after covert that you wait until you
actually know that you can go
and that is creating some issues for our
promoters um
and but it's one of those things that
we're just having to deal with from an
operations point of view
uh look the only other two things i'd
like to draw your attention to um
in the library range of programs just
the the degree and the range of
different partnerships that our team
have in the community with corrections
with wells south and we're also with a
number of schools that we're engaging
with
um
especially around the change to the
history curriculum
um so just some yeah we are evolving and
we're keeping up with what's going on
we're also using our community partners
to affect i think really well
and that's also similar to the message
in hey wakatuya
if you look at the
participation numbers you'll see that
there's a asterisk below the table which
also talks about the number of school
children that have engaged in
the services outside of the facility
itself
so yeah i think good effort from the
team so i'll pass over to trudy unless
there's any questions
thanks steve um look i'll echo your
comments around um the community
engagement we've always seen from from
the library for example
uh lots of innovation
uh over previous years and that's
continuing with uh with new staff and
they're looking for new ways to to
activate the space after we've gone
through
uh and changed it i see school groups
being on taking are being taken on tours
around town
um a lot of stuff that we just haven't
necessarily seen
in the past so it's
it's great to see those things happening
uh
we know from as you've pointed out with
hawakitui the
the engagement they were able to get
through janet dewitt's last exhibition
which saw it extended is great and
council gave an indication that it wants
to see that type of
external engagement
increasing so it's really positive
counsellors there's two recommendations
that the report is
received and the change to clause 15 1
of
ibm's constitution
so i'm part of that i'm not going to
move it i shall move in that case with
you
thank you
questions or comments
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against carried
which brings us to the end of the
public part of the meeting
we will move into
public excluded
to
discuss the uh items as laid out on on
the agenda the receiving of minutes of
the community well-being fund committee
meeting and the confirmation of minutes
from the
performance policy and partnerships last
meeting
and for the reasons as outlined under
section 721 of the local government act
once we have moved into public excluded
and allowing for uh mr grant and mr
mckenzie to remain part of the meeting
it's my intention to adjourn the meeting
so we don't have to ask the public to
leave because we have an extraordinary
council meeting to follow and once we've
dealt with the public excluded part of
the extraordinary council meeting then
we'll come back and finish this off
everybody comfortable with that process
cool well i'll move that we're going to
public excluded for the reasons as our
sorry councillor amongst um because it's
just the moving of minutes if there's no
discussion about any of those public
excluded minutes i'm happy to move both
seats of those minutes
will you have a second that okay
i'm comfortable receiving that
counsellors you're comfortable with that
in that case i'll put the motion since
it's been put by councillor edmondson
seconded
i missed your second
councillor partner thank you all in
favor aye okay against right carrie
christmas to the end of ppp and